l'application kovy développé depuis
plusieurs semaines par l'institut
québécois d'intelligence artificielle
sur la direction de yushu a bendjo n'a
pas été retenue par le gouvernement
fédéral valérie pisano est présidente et
chef de la direction de millas de cet
institut bonsoir valérie pisano devant
soi qu'est ce qui s'est passé comment
vous expliquer la décision du
gouvernement fédéral
écoutez faut savoir que depuis le débat
depuis départs par an on avait une
entente avec le gouvernement fédéral qui
était de développer l'application donc
une première phase qui allait durer à
peu près deux mois
vous vous rappellerez que dès le début
de la pandémie dans la mare fédéral
avait choisi d'investir dans des projets
de recherche qui avait le potentiel nous
aider avec la gestion de la crise chap
et dans ce contexte là que nous on est
arrivé dans le portrait avec ovi et on
s'était entendu qu'on allait développer
l'application n'allait aller jusqu'au
bout de nos travaux mais qui aurait
toujours un moment où a qu'à voir les
décider si oui ou non il ya une
application de traçage suit la quête est
donc ça peut être un peu du clan dès le
départ puis le effectivement il ya
quelques jours on a su que effectivement
se serait pas produit si jamais il y
avait une application qui allait de
l'avant et pourquoi c'est pas que vick
est ce que qu'est ce que le gouvernement
vous dis mais je tente la question elle
me répondit par les gens de ta voix le
jarret pas la prétention de répondre
pour eux je pense cependant être assez
juste de dire que le modèle qu'on
proposait était différent
donc si on compare avec ce qui se fait
ailleurs dans le monde le nôtre était
plus sophistiquées ou qui complique il
eu selon comme on veut le voir mais il
exclut l'intelligence artificielle le
grand avantage de faire ça c'est que ça
nous permettait de prédire si les gens
étaient peut-être contagieux et donc de
gérer les éclosions avant qu'elle ne se
manifeste le désavantage d'intelligence
artificielle c'est qu'on doit recueillir
de la denis on avait mis en place un
protocole qui était qui était très
respectueux de la vie privée qui
protégeait les données déjà mais comme
on le vit dans l'immédiat il ya eu
beaucoup de débats beaucoup de questions
dont deux ça donc je crois que tu avoir
choisi une approche qui était peut-être
moins controversée d'un haut niveau de
la collection la sécurité et donc
on peut imaginer qu'à ottawa on était
très sensible on s'inquiétait qui est
trop de données etc on est trop loin
dans la vie privée des gens mais je
pense qu'on s'inquiétait surtout de ce
que les citoyens alors pensé parce que
pour être honnête nos travaux avaient
été audités on avait très vite le
commissaire à la vie privée du canada
dès le début du mois d'avril ils
s'étaient montrés très satisfaits de la
façon qu'on réfléchit c'est ça on a
gagné en place de protocoles de sécurité
avec les plus hauts standards des
protocoles très novateur donc il n'ya
pas vraiment je préfère une inquiétude
lequel quelque chose à vivre et je pense
c'est plus est ce que les gestes que les
citoyens étaient prêts pour ça vous
l'avez vu le lieu un débat un monstre le
dans l'immédiat mais la caisse qu'elle
donnait qu'est ce que les gens vont
faire avec ça on s'est même fait accuser
à tort le projet allait privatiser c'est
donner leurs clés compagnie privée elle
en bénéficier donc je pense que c'est
devenu une discussion peut-être trop
chargé
l'important c'est de déployer la
technologie qui peut aider les gens et
donc que cette folle moment pour kobe
c'est peut-être une façon de la voix est
ce qu'il ya une incompréhension de
l'intelligence artificielle et pensez
vous que les décideurs comprennent mal
intelligence artificielle ça n'est pas
lesquelles mais effectivement les
agences officielles ces petits tout
simple et c'est très complexe
darga sont dans sa version la plus
simple c'est des mathématiques des
mathématiques qui sont sophistiquées au
sens où on n'a pas besoin de leur donner
la formule elle cherche elle même la
formule et cherche elle même à
comprendre qu'est ce qui se passe donc
d'un quai de la criée de la ville t on
la comprend pas encore que cet ce virus
là où on ne comprend pas encore et donc
on est des hypothèses on a des études
cliniques mais on a vite encore un petit
peu l aveugle avait de la donner et de
l'intelligence artificielle on aurait
tout très rapidement définir toutes
sortes de paramètres
par exemple un exemple très complet
c'est un maître c'est u2 à être à
l'extérieur à l'intérieur on a des
travaux qui inspire le l'édition la
santé publique mais avec intelligence à
si l on aurait pu accélérer de façon
considérable s'est découvert que c'est
l'application qu'ovide shield développée
par sharp et faye qui aurait obtenu les
faveurs du gouvernement fédéral c'est
quoi la différence avec votre
application
oui donc elle
quelles sont les actions d'al est très
semblable à celle qui a été déployée la
part d'autres pays dans le monde au sens
où elle est et ce qu'on appelle direct
et elle fait de la multiplication
d'expositions
donc ce que ça veut dire concrètement
c'est que vous l'avez sur votre
téléphone et la journée que vous avez
été en contact avec quelqu'un qui reçoit
un test positif l'on vous avions déjà
qui balaye est quelqu'un qui a été testé
positif c'est à votre tour d'aller vous
faire tester doivent faire dépister
dans le cadre de vie nous c'était de la
production donc il y avait cette
fonctionnalité ne la journée quelques 20
tests mais on pouvait alizés les gens
trois quatre cinq jours d'avancé parce
qu'on n'a pas vraiment besoin d'attendre
le test vous stockez de l'apparition de
symptômes
aussitôt que beaucoup de gens dans votre
dans votre quartier ou dans votre milieu
de travail qui ont des symptômes déjà
aussi que vous êtes probablement plus
exposés donc l'idée c'était pour le
citoyen d'avoir un outil quotidien qui
lui permet de prendre des décisions
mieux informées et des trucs ridant
avant même d'avoir des symptômes parce
qu'on ne sait malheureusement la
couvaison cela transmet alors qu'on
n'est pas symptomatique
la plupart déjà la journée qui se
réveille on l'acquiert de la toux rsa la
maison n'est pas le problème le problème
y ait dans les jours où on le sait pas
qu'on leur ai donc ces questions un peu
notre prémisse de départ un outil pour
les citoyens quand ce pour la santé
publique mais quand on regarde son
niveau statistique on aurait vu le
niveau de risque déjà augmenté avant
même que ya eu des résultats positifs et
donc ça leur donne un outil pourrait
beaucoup plus préventif dans leurs
interventions
maintenant pour que cette application
puisse aller de l'avant qui je comprends
bien que vous continuez à travailler
là-dessus à paul à poster et google
pluie exige que toutes les applications
développées en lien avec la coved 19
soit endossé par un gouvernement ou une
instance de santé reconnu
quel est donc l'avenir de kovy à toute
transparence à court terme
on se concentre sur finaliser la
livraison de notre prototype sont vêtus
et ce mot là on va rentrer tous nos
travaux disponible autant le code donc
le fonctionnement de l'application que
ce qu'on appelle un livre blanc que tout
le raisonnement de m
on avait déjà publié un premier livre
blanc vont publier d'autres et donc on
va finir nos travaux on va faire une
très importante je pense contribution
scientifique qui a créé cette année là
pouvoir parce qu'on s'affole un dizaine
d'autres projets là où on se concentre
sur l'application d'intelligence
artificielle pour nous aider à gérer la
pandémie notamment au niveau des
médicaments au niveau des traitements
des patients très bien on va continuer
donc de vous suivre avec beaucoup
d'intérêt merci beaucoup
valérie pisano merci à vous